[Danny Hillis] It was getting to be the early
90s and people were still thinking about the
future as being in the year 2000.
You know, I realized that the future had kind
of been shrinking by one year per year
for my whole life.
That's when I started designing this clock
that would last for 10,000 years.
[Stewart Brand] I heard from Danny Hillis
about his idea to build a Stonehenge-scale
mechanical clock that would tick once a century,
bong every thousand years, and,
after much longer than that, the cuckoo comes out.
[Danny] Steward realized the 10 000 year clock
would change how people thought about time
long before I did, even when I was building it.
[music]
[music and ambient noise]
[Stewart] The Clock is an artwork that is
already an expression of thinking long term.
[Brian Eno] The Clock is a provocation, in
a sense.
Is it possible that we could be around for
10 000 years?
What if there's a war?
Or, what if asteroid hits the Earth and there's
a nuclear winter?
Even saying "what if" is starting to do what
the clock is intended to do.
[Bells Peal]
[Music]
Once you are holding these longer time frames
in mind that starts to raise the question of
What do you do on Monday?
Does your behavior start to reflect this larger
frame?
[Music]